-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
in "Parks and Recreation"
and blockbuster franchises
like "Jurassic World"
and Marvel's
"Guardians of the Galaxy."
He stars in the
"Super Mario Bros. Movie,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX now.
Let's take a look.
-Just pop in this pipe,
and we're on our way.
-Oh.
-It's the only way to fly, man.
[ Warp pipe noise ]
[ Laughing ]
Whoo!
-Oh, wow.
Love these pipe--
Aaah!!
Yaaaah!
Unh!
Ugh!
Ohh!
-Whoo!
-Unh!
[ Warp pipe noise ]
[ Groans ]
-Here we are -- palace doors.
Bing bang boom.
♪♪
Come on!
Whoo!
-Please welcome back
to the show
our good friend
Chris Pratt, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, old friend.
-Whoo!
It's good to be here.
-You brought a box.
-I brought a very special box
directly from the
Mushroom Kingdom to you.
-Oh, my God.
This is beautiful.
Look at this --
says, "Super Mario Bros."
-Courtesy of --
-There you go.
-It's the
"Super Mario Bros. Movie."
It's an official collectible.
They're very rare.
-Ooh!
-Coin.
-Wow! Look at that.
-Yes, yes.
-That's a super...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I bashed my skull against
numerous bricks in the city
finding that.
[ Laughter ]
So I hope you appreciate it.
-I do appreciate it.
You know what
I bet you appreciate.
Since I last saw you, you have
had two baby girls.
-Man, I have, yeah.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Between you and I,
we're gonna repopulate.
-We are gonna repop--
I added -- I added a girl
since I last saw you, as well.
-Amazing.
-Here we go. How is it?
How's being a girl dad?
-I love it, man. It's really --
It's really great.
Obviously, you know,
I do have a 10-year-old son,
so this is my first time
having daughters.
And, man, it's just --
It's fantastic.
They really -- you know,
you hear that maybe
the experience is different.
And it really is.
And in my experience, I mean, my
my daughter Lyla is so girly.
She picks out all --
I picked her up yesterday.
She goes, "Oh, daddy,
that's a cute outfit.
Look, you have
little cute pockets."
[ Laughter ]
That's not something
Jack ever said to me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, my boys have
not mentioned my pockets once.
-No, no. Yeah.
-And I put a lot of work
into my pockets.
-Yeah, I know you!
It's nice to have
a little appreciation
for the pocket game.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I am also --
You have a father-in-law...
-Yes.
-...of note.
Your father-in-law
is Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-Correct. Yes, yes.
-Now, that is --
that's got to be surreal,
because I'm assuming we're kind
of from the same generation.
He's a huge deal.
He's an inspiration.
-Yeah, it is pretty surreal.
I mean, I've gotten
to obviously know him now
as just a regular guy
and all of that.
He's a great grandfather,
a great dad,
a good father-in-law,
and he's got a wealth
of experience, oddly,
in the world of promoting
blockbuster action movies.
It's like, who else are you
gonna talk to
about that kind of stuff?
So that's pretty cool.
But, yeah.
-My father-in-law would never
be able to help me out
with that.
-"Let me ask you something.
What do you think?
What should I say?"
But it's been --
it's been very nice.
He's a great dude.
We play chess a lot.
And he loves his grandchildren.
-Who's better at chess?
-He -- I've never beat him.
-Okay.
-He's incredible.
He's really good.
-I've spent a very little
amount of time with him,
but the most fun thing
about spending time
with Arnold Schwarzenegger
is he sounds
exactly like
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-Yeah, right?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. You're like, "That's a
really good Arnold you do.
That's -- Wow, that's good."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, was this --
was "Super Mario Bros.",
was that a game
you were playing as a kid?
-Man, I -- yes.
Honestly,
if I had to count up the hours,
and this is no hyperbole,
I think it's close to
25,000,000 hours...
[ Laughter ]
...that I played
"Super Mario Bros."
I saw the movie,
and the movie's fantastic,
and there's all these
great Easter eggs,
and the -- and the sound,
the soundtrack,
it lifts from the soundtrack
of the games.
And I just had this Pavlovian
response to like,
the coin and -- and landing
on a turtle
and breaking a brick
and getting the star.
I was like, "Br-br-br!"
I just like --
[ Laughter ]
I've been -- 30 years
I've been preparing
for this movie.
And as an audience,
you really kind of --
you realize just how hypnotizing
that music has been.
So I don't think people
are quite ready
for what's coming to them,
but it's very promising for us.
I mean, I think there's going
to be a lot of these movies
coming out
because it is so good.
-And, Jack, your son, he also
dabbles in this game, right?
He knows it?
-He's a "Smash Bros" guy.
-Okay, gotcha.
-You know, he plays "Smash"
on his -- on his Switch.
So he hasn't played --
I don't think we've played
the original
Nintendo Entertainment System
"Super Mario Bros." game,
the game that I played
so much as a kid.
But he plays like "Mario Kart"
and "Smash Bros."
-Were you also --
were you the generation
that would actually go
to the arcade
and play coin-operated games?
-I was.
I was right in that sweet spot.
So, it was late '80s
when I first was introduced
to the "Super Mario Bros."
or "Mario Bros."
arcade-style game.
I grew up in a very small town,
and there wasn't anything to do.
And so I'd come home
from school,
and I would walk
across the street
to this little
coin-operated laundromat,
Fowlds Laundry, still
in Lake Stevens, Washington.
And there was
an arcade game there.
I never had a quarter, but I
would just stare at the game.
I'd hit the buttons.
I was like,
"Maybe one day
I'll be able to play this."
And then I found out
that Alfy's Pizza,
also still in Lake Stevens,
had a jukebox that was
tucked into the corner,
and the coin return
was on the back side.
So people would put
their money in --
"Eh, this piece of crap
ate my coins."
But I knew
they were in the back.
And my -- my little
9-year-old arm
would reach back in,
dislocate my shoulder pulling --
I checked --
That was my routine.
Every day after school,
go to Alfy's,
check the coin return.
If there were coins,
go to Fowlds.
[ Laughter ]
-So you were just walking
back and forth?
-Yeah. I beat a pa--
I beat a triangular path
between Alfy's and Fowlds.
-Was there something about
somebody would give you money
if you got in the dryer?
-Yes. Yeah.
If I -- if coin fishing
didn't work out at Alfy's,
I'd talk to Jason,
who was the teenager
who seemed like an adult
at the time,
but he was the teenager
who operated the --
or, you know, ran the desk.
-At the laundromat.
And he would give me a quarter.
In exchange, I'd have to get
in the tumble dryer.
[ Laughter ]
And he'd hit tumble dry.
This is kind of win-win
for me as a kid.
-I would say!
-It's pretty great.
-As a kid, what are
you complaining about?
-Giant tumble dryer?
I'm like, "Pa-tunk, pa-tunk,
pa-tunk!"
"I can't believe it!
I'm living the dream!"
[ Laughter ]
And then I get the quarter.
It was amazing.
-I mean, I guess all my
questions for this
are really probably for Jason.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And also we have
some members of --
some -- some
gentlemen in uniform
that'd like to talk
to Jason, too, about...
-Putting a --throwing a kid
in a tumble dryer.
-Yeah, I loved it, though.
I mean, I was --
I always wanted to be a stuntman
growing up,
so I was always --
my brother and I
were always throwing ourselves
down the stairs.
-Yeah, so tumble dryer
was nothing.
-Tumble dryer's nothing.
-Yeah, come on.
-Yeah, it's easy quarter.
-It was the easiest quarter
I ever made.
-Best five minutes of my life
for that quarter.
[ Laughter ]
I come out a little smaller.
-You know, last week,
we had your old
"Parks and Rec" colleague
Adam Scott on the show.
-Yeah!
And, you know, I'm wondering,
do you guys still keep in touch?
I mean, it was a really
close group of people.
You were here in 2015,
I guess, was it
where we all -- we had
a cast show where you were
all out here
for the season finale.
-Yeah, I remember that.
I think, like --
Wasn't Aubrey
making out with Jim O'Heir?
-Yeah, here.
-And Nick was playing guitar.
And -- Oh, those were
the good old days, man.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah. We still --
we still keep in touch.
We have a text thread that goes,
and, you know,
people's birthdays
and celebrations.
And obviously so many
of the cast members
are doing such amazing things.
-It's really nice time
for all of you.
-Checking in
and supporting each other.
Yeah, for sure. We still have
that text thread going.
-And you're gonna
have to start another one
because your time with
"Guardians"
is coming to a close, as well,
which has been
an incredible journey
with another special
group of people.
-Thanks, guys. Thank you. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think people forget that,
you know,
"Guardians" wasn't
a property people knew as well.
And it was -- I don't think
people had the same anticipation
or thought it was gonna do
as well as it ended up doing.
-No, they really didn't.
I mean, I remember --
In fact, on our last day of
shooting on "Volume 3,"
we knew this was the end,
and -- and it was
a little bit like,
you know, the last day
of your senior year.
It's like
you're excited for summer,
but are you ever gonna
see your friends again?
It's like that --
that trepidation.
You don't really want
to walk away.
And I was just --
I addressed the cast
and the crew and the director,
and I said -- and I
pulled up from my phone
like about 10 headlines
from the press
when the movie
was being released,
all of which completely
predicted this massive bomb.
They're like, "Are you ready?"
I remember the press.
"Are you ready to be
Marvel's first big bomb?"
"Why Is anyone gonna
watch this movie?"
"No one gives a crap about
the Guardians of the Galaxy."
"Wait. It's a raccoon
and a tree?"
"There's no A-list stars
in this thing."
"So this is going to suck."
And I'm like, "Oh, my God."
At the time, you know,
I was like,
"It probably is gonna suck,
and this is it for me!
At least I got to try."
And then, you know, it came out,
and by the grace of God,
it did very well.
And we're still working, so...
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, it's really exciting.
Man, what a delight
to have you back here.
-Dude, it's --
-It's really always so special
to see you.
Thank you so much.
You guys, that's Chris Pratt.
"Super Mario Bros.",
theaters and IMAX now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."